all right so Ryan Johnson's latest
mystery sequel Glass Onion on Knives Out
mystery is finally on Netflix so you
pour Chumps that missed it during that
random week in theaters are finally in
luck famed detective Benoit Blanc is
back at it so in this video we're gonna
be slicing open the Glass Onion and do a
full breakdown of the film explain the
twist ending some Easter eggs hidden
details you may have missed along with
our reaction and review of this latest
Netflix mystery movie with that out of
the way a huge thank you for clicking
this I'm your host Jared now let's get
into Glass Onion
foreign
[Music]
so Glass Onion quickly introduces our
group of players all having some sort of
connection or let's say friendship with
a billionaire playboy philanthropist by
the name of Miles Braun each receiving a
similar mystery puzzle boxes while each
jumps on a group call to solve the
puzzle together the character slowly
revealed themselves Claire de bella the
governor of Connecticut now running for
Senate Lionel to Sant the head scientist
for Miles company named Alpha birdie j a
former supermodel turned fashion
designer and Duke Cody a twitch streamer
and men's rights activist along with
them is Peg who is Birdie's assistant
and whiskey Duke's girlfriend and twitch
Channel assistant so hit that like
button fam together they solve the
various puzzles of the puzzle box
revealing an onion looking shape with a
personal invite to bronze private Greek
island for the weekend murder mystery
party getaway from the craziness of
2020. ironically the symbol on the
invite is that of a Greek evil eye or
mati which usually symbolizes a curse
given by one person to another by the
way of spiteful or a bitter look hinting
Brawn may have some sort of power over
this group Janelle Monae's character
Cassandra Andy brand also receives a
puzzle box however was not included in
the group call and instead shows her
hilariously smashing the puzzle box open
rather than solving each of the puzzles
meaning she's unlike the others and her
current situation being in a robe in an
unfinished basement adds to this Benoit
Blanc makes his appearance playing the
social video game Among Us this both
gained popularity back in 2020 but also
is essentially a murder mystery game
funny enough he's playing with a handful
of real celebrities each having a tie to
some sort of mystery series themselves
Stephen Sondheim co-wrote the last
Sheila a 70s mystery movie Natasha Leone
is set to star in Johnson's upcoming
mystery series poker face Angela
Lansbury starred in The Classic drama
Murder She Wrote and Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
previously played himself in the 1954
murder mystery Fletch unfortunately
block desperately needs a real mystery
because he is just withering away in the
tub there's a copy of Kane's Jawbone on
the floor a murder mystery puzzle from
the 1930s featuring several time jumps
foreshadowing that the film won't follow
a chronological structure when all of a
sudden a knock on his door reveals him
receiving a mystery puzzle box himself
Blanc is seen checking his watch which
happens to be an Omega the same watch
brand that James Bond wore of which
Daniel Craig portrayed this character so
like it's all connected man but he's
winning for the ferry to take him to
bronze Island as all of the others show
up again with this taking place during
the 2020 lockdown The Masks of each
character really shows us their true
character Blanc Lionel and Peg wear
their masks and social distance rule
followers Claire with hers under her
nose and money in her mouth she does one
thing but kind of feels another like a
true politician birdie sporting a mesh
mask which which honestly that does
nothing this could even be a reference
to Lana Del Rey wearing one in a music
video back in 2020 and Duke and whiskey
don't wear masks at all hugging everyone
else further showing the wealth power
and Technology of Braun Ethan Hawke just
makes a random Cameo here's them of any
potential illnesses so masks will no
longer be needed Andy makes a last
minute arrival as the rest of the group
are shocked by her appearance block is
informed that Andy was actually booted
out of bronze company without time so
her being there is a bit odd upon
arriving to the island miles Brawn
played by Elon Norton I mean Edward
Norton greets them with playing The
Beatles song Blackbird on the exact same
guitar Paul McCartney wrote the song on
uh allegedly here you instantly know
bronze character by his actions one he
instantly discards this treasured guitar
with history and story like it's nothing
and him playing Blackbird is a bit
hypocritical because it's said that the
inspiration for this song came from the
Civil Rights troubles in 1960 Southern
United States but yet he has just found
out that he screwed over a black woman
and kicked her out of his company so uh
yeah Braun is uh he's starting off great
there's pleasantries between the group
bronze saying that the whole weekend is
just them until a random dude just walks
by just us hey
hey bro not here
who's that
that's Daryl this is a great ongoing
joke throughout the film but this is
actor Noah segan he may look familiar
because he did play Trooper Wagner in
the first Knives Out film and has been
featured in Ryan Johnson's other films
like all of them another ongoing Cameo
or voice Cameo is when Braun is showing
off the Glass Onion and the hourly dong
is heard the dong is recorded by Joseph
Gordon-Levitt who has also been in all
of Johnson's other films revealed by
Johnson in an interview now the first
bit of the mystery at the core of Glass
Onion is revealed as Blanc was not
originally invited to the murder mystery
weekend someone must have reset the
boxes and sent him theirs but Braun
argues this legitimizes the mystery
having the greatest detective ever to be
in attendance while Blanc pushes back a
bit sane Mr Brown I've learned through
bitter experience that an anonymous
invitation is not to be trifle with
which ties back to the first first film
with Ransom anonymously hiring Blanc
hoping to frame Marta down at the pool
Braun mentions some Jared aletto hard
kabucha which is a slight reference to
Leto being a free spirit type I don't
know let's call it that but more so
their roles together in David Fincher's
Fight Club Braun apparently lives in the
Stone Age though because he gets
everything sent to him via a fax machine
which sort of popped up earlier when
Lionel was complaining about the insane
things he is faxed like AI in dogs
equals discourse probably being a
reference to the real course of Boston
Robotics and their dog robots being
useful like moving things like luggage
but the discourse comes from law
enforcement using them to fire weapons
so everything in this layered Glass
Onion has a meaning if you're looking
deep enough block learns more about the
group why they are all connected and why
they are quote disruptors First birdie
sweeping the market with her sweetie
pants fashion line I feel like this is
actually taking real life inspiration
from Kate Hudson and her fabletics
fashion line Duke becoming the first
twitch streamer to hit a million
subscribers Claire being a stay-at-home
mom with her shaking up the political
sector and Lionel pushing the boundaries
of science Braun mentions an infraction
point which I'm pretty sure is entirely
made up pushing the limits of his
company Alpha as well but gets cut off
by Andy blowing up each of their spots
Lino's research being funded by Braun
Claire's campaign being bankrolled by
Braun Braun was an angel investor in
sweetie pants after birdie went on Oprah
comparing herself to Harriet Tubman
which is definitely a reference to the
real life Rachel Hollis motivational and
lifestyle influencer making the same
claim and Braun coming to Duke's rescue
after being banned from twitch for
selling boner pills basically each of
them is owed a debt to Braun under a
curse of the evil eye hanging on to his
golden titties and each has a reason to
kill him the party kicks off with it
first being revealed that miles is
renting the Mona Lisa yes the Mona Lisa
from the French to again show off his
wealth power and Status explaining that
the painting has something so simple to
it but the longer you stare the more
complex it gets much like the mystery of
Glass Onion but luckily safeguards for
sound and Fire have been put in place
but in bran fashion an override button
has been installed the reason for the
Mona Lisa is that Braun is about to
unveil the new source of renewable
hydrogen-based solid energy called clear
yes that's with a K edgy right this is
what Lionel and the other scientists
were talking about at the beginning of
the film arguing it hasn't even been
tested but Braun reveals that the entire
Glass Onion is being powered by clear no
surprise the light fixture above the
table during dinner is shaped like a
giant clear crystal foreshadowing later
events of the film The Murder Mystery
kicks oh wow okay that that was supposed
to take the whole weekend but block
solves it in a matter of minutes
basically ruining the weekend for this
very fun explanation of events Braun
upset saying he paid Jillian Flynn tons
of money to craft the mystery and twists
she of course is the author of some
great mystery novels out there like Gone
Girl and sharp objects so it's nice to
you know see a nod to her work however
block says it was all purposeful warning
Brawn that bringing all of these people
to a secluded Island each with a motive
to kill him would be like leaving a
loaded gun on a table and turning the
lights off not safe and not smart at all
tensions grow hotter between the group
when suddenly Duke can't breathe
dropping his drink and dropping dead no
sign of an obstructive Airway just
dunzos unfortunately the fair area and
authorities cannot come due to low tide
so the group has to hang out until 6 a.m
miles notices Duke had picked up his
drink by accident and whoever spiked at
the drink actually wanted miles dead
suspicious of everyone now block notices
Duke's gun is gone too and it gets worse
as Braun had scheduled the power to go
off during the murder mystery party as
everything goes dark everyone panics
running amok in the Glass Onion no one
trusts anyone when block runs into Andy
mentioning something along the lines of
only one piece of evidence is needed
before she is shot by a stranger using
Duke's gun everyone is now a suspect and
the Killer is still on the Loose as the
film slowly zooms into Mona Lisa's eyes
reinforcing the statement from earlier
it's never what you thought you were
looking at as the biggest Twist of the
film is revealed so taking a page from
Kane's Jawbone mentioned earlier the
film flashes back to when Blanc received
the mystery box delivery but it wasn't
delivered by a FedEx driver it was
Andy's twin sister Helen the old dead
twin Switcheroo same actor playing the
different character Trope now if you're
paying attention before the flashback
block does slip up calling her Helen
instead of Andy
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway Helen snoops around finding an
email that her sister had sent earlier
to the disruptors saying that she'd
found it she's gonna burn down the
entire Empire and gonna give them one
last chance to make things right with a
picture of her holding a red envelope of
course alluding to her being pushed out
of Alpha and them testifying against her
however Helen looked everywhere but the
Red Envelope was nowhere to be found the
two hatch a crazy plan for them to both
attend the mystery party weekend having
Helen go undercover as her sister to
find her true killer before this Parent
Trap type plan Helen informs block of
the past 10 years before the group was
rich and famous or even met Brawn Andy
was the one who saw potential in all of
them later introducing Braun to the
group now you're probably asking
yourself why the heck is Edward Norton
dressed like Tom Cruise from Magna Olia
I'm sure Johnson thought it would be
cheeky but both characters share similar
characteristics being these scummy men
talking themselves into success and
those flowing locks
but also David Bowie's star man is
playing in the background adding more to
Braun essentially seeing hope in the
Youth of the group and how they can
change the world how they are disruptors
each slowly finding success though Andy
is the one to come up with the Alpha
Company idea on a napkin partnering with
Braun and bringing the rest of the crew
with them Braun wants more with the
clear program rocking an inspired Steve
Jobs look with a black turtleneck and
blue jeans as this kind of feels like an
apple situation as Andy is pushed out of
the company by everyone testifying
against her claiming that napkin idea
was originally created by Braun Andy
then finds the original napkin in a copy
of the innovators dilemma which tackles
the concept of disruptive Technologies
and this is where Andy sends the email
that the Helen originally came across
now flashback to the island as we see
the events from Helen's point of view
rather than what the movie has shown us
so far as she overhears a conversation
with Lionel and Claire stating that they
both signed off unclear but know that
it's a heck of a bad idea with leaks of
massive hydrogen gas in the air in homes
and this could be a whole Hindenburg
situation now the Hindenburg was a giant
Airship from the 1930s filled with
hydrogen and exploded due to a fire
killing dozens basically clear is a bit
of a foggy product some of the group
lets Helen know that none of them
emailed back because they they called
they didn't want a paper trail and
instead showed up at Andy's home but she
wasn't there with Duke saying he almost
got pancaked on the way over another
celebrity Cameo is Serena Williams on
the workout screen and if you pause you
can see what book she is reading it's
gravity's rainbow which is a reference
to the first knives out when block
claims that no one has read the book
gravity's rainbow
it's a novel yeah I know
I haven't read it though neither have I
nobody is during the party Helen
purposely started the fight with Duke to
be sure to have a reason to leave and
search everyone's room for the Red
Envelope her phone continues to buzz
finally checking to realize that her
sister's death had finally been leaked
to the press all these friends and
family were sending their regards but if
you look closely the names featured are
a handful of editors and visual effects
people who worked on the film this is
bad news though because Helen's cover is
essentially blown leading to right where
the time Jump happened and Helen not
Andy is shocked but something we didn't
see before is her pocket diary stop the
bullet she did not die block needs to
search the Glass Onion for the envelope
and with the killer thinking that Helen
is dead they douse her in the Jeremy
Renner hot sauce from earlier this and
the hot sauce in the eye bit has got to
be a reference to the Jeremy Renner hot
ones episode where he gets hot sauce in
his AI as Blanc distracts everyone who
may or may not be the killer hella makes
her way up to the Glass Onion only to
find the red envelope had been staring
us right in the face the entire time
right behind the forged one block comes
to his own infraction point that Miles
Braun wasn't some sort of complicated
genius but a straight up idiot making up
words paying for puzzle boxes and
Mysteries again tying into it's never
what you thought you were looking for no
one really tried to kill Braun it was
him who killed Duke if you pay close
attention Braun handed Duke his drink
Duke didn't accidentally pick it up this
is because Duke saw Brawn leaving Andy's
house the night she died Braun had
killed Andy and Duke was the only
witness adding that he had almost hit
him in his baby blue sports car then
when Duke's Google Alerts informed him
of Andy's death Duke saw this as an
opportunity to blackmail him into
getting essentially that Spa part on the
alpha Cable News Network Brian couldn't
have this happen so he slipped a little
bit of pineapple juice into his drink
because at the Docks from earlier before
boarding the ship Duke admits that he is
deathly allergic no pineapple on that
right Duke don't dance
Ron then stole his phone and silenced
the Google Alerts so the others wouldn't
discover Andy's death and that Helen had
taken her place Braun is a certified
dum-dum nothing smart about his plan at
all he literally stole blanc's
hypothetical scenario of leaving a
loaded gun on a table and then turning
off the lights what an idiot Helen
reveals she has the napkin to take him
down claiming the original as the name
of the bar on it but Braun burns the
napkin evidence out of her hands meaning
that they are back to square one there's
nothing they can do block even says that
it's out of his hands nothing the courts
or authorities can do now Helen goes on
a hissy fit smashing all of bronze
sculpture treasured items lighting the
bar on fire but there's something he
missed Blanc had slipped her the raw
clear from earlier Helen goes straight
up Walter White throwing it into the
fire exploding the entire Glass Onion
because the hydrogen elements were
highly flammable like the Hindenburg
even the Glass Onion Dome looks like it
has the same outside structuring as the
Hindenburg the entire Place Goes Up in
Flames with the final move of Helens
being the destruction of the Mona Lisa
Nate King calls Mona Lisa begins to play
as Helen makes her way over to the
override button as that some beach Burns
Braun knows that he's absolutely
but it's even worse than he thought
because the Mona Lisa is destroyed but
clear the energy source is going to be
the thing that's reported on having done
it everything he's scummily built is
done but at least he got his wish of
forever being Remembered in the same
breath as the Mona Lisa Glass Onion
comes to a close Helen winning and
slowly zooming into her face similar to
the Mona Lisa right before the time jump
from earlier symbolizing she is one the
credits perfectly finished with the
Beatles Glass Onion plane wrapping up
the many different layers of the plot
with multiple suspects all of their own
motives secrets and ways their lives and
careers overlap also kind of paralleling
the first knives out with everyone
trying to leech off of one character
before we wrap things up there are so
many clever red herrings references and
other details tucked away in Glass Onion
that we gotta talk about first of course
being the constant Mr X Ryan Johnson
subtly hid in plain sight to throw the
viewers off of Miles Braun being the
actual killer for example starting with
some of the characters specifically
Batista's Duke Cody using an Android
phone instead of iPhones the reason so
is because in the first knives out it
was kind of a small detail that actually
gave away the murder because they were
using an Android while everyone else was
using an iPhone but this time they did
the old Switcheroo the missing knife
from the kitchen being revealed birdie
had taken it and described as quote
Dangerous by block earlier in the film
meaning she could have and would have
killed even the conversation between
Helen and block in the bathroom has
Birdie's face smack dab in the middle of
the little mirror in the background
making you think the movie is being Sly
giving you hints when it's not or at
least that's how I felt but aside from
the red herrings there were quite a few
small details and dialogue that spell
out miles Braun is most likely the
murderer where the envelope is and Miles
being an idiot it without any sort of
original idea so if you put on your
little detective hat you may have
noticed one of the first things Lionel
says about Braun is that he's gonna get
somebody killed the puzzle box in the
opening has a specific puzzle that looks
identical to the framed napkin we see
later there's even a little red square
where we later discovered the original
envelope was hidden Block's speech about
the truth being hidden under a pile of
Lies the pile of Lies was the forged
napkin with the real one underneath when
Braun leans in to talk about Andy in the
good old days of the Glass Onion he has
shrouded in darkness while block is in
the light being a good versus evil
symbolism on screen when Braun jumps on
the couch after Duke's death we can
briefly see Duke's phone poking out of
his back pocket this happens a couple of
times before it's finally actually
revealed by block towards the end of the
film a brief look at Helen's notepad
shows miles already has motive and
opportunity next to his name before her
and Blanc can even get to the island and
investigate we later discover Braun is
an unoriginal idiot by all means just
ripping things off from Steve Jobs
iconic look the Tom Cruise looked from
Magnolia the events of the evening being
stolen from block when he explains
everything earlier in the Glass Onion
claiming he crafted the dinner murder
mystery but it was actually purchased
from someone even burning the envelope
after Lionel suggests it and some of the
paintings in the main area are upside
down like the rothko here but the very
first sign of bronze idiocy he's a phony
all of it is him playing Paul
McCartney's guitar when we first see him
Braun is playing right-handed Paul
McCartney famously plays left-handed
meaning Braun doesn't have a damn clue
what he's doing now to symbolize the end
of his Empire are all of the Omega
symbols hidden on the island seems a
little weird for a company called Alpha
to have omega symbols as you can see on
the boat the robe Claire is wearing the
pendant Lionel wears at the dinner party
and watch that Blanc wears is an Omega
and get this Alpha is the first letter
in the Greek alphabet while Omega is the
last letter meaning that this is the end
of bronze story and if you know your
Greek mythology Cassandra is a fraternal
twin to helenus so Andy and Helen in the
movie and Cassandra was gifted with
seeing the Prophecies of the future aka
the future of alpha company but was
cursed into no one believing her by
Apollo in the movie's case the dangers
of clear and another myth mentions the
arrival of Helen will spark the downfall
and destruction of Troy during the
Trojan War which translates to Helen in
the movie dismantling the alpha Empire
when she shows up to the island maybe
I'm reaching maybe a bit but I I don't
know it's there anyway I got a kick out
of Glass Onion lots and lots of layers
to the character's mystery everything at
play I loved the the set design of the
main room in the Glass Onion the jokes
and random references Johnson threw in
there were great like the Daryl
interruptions every time I got a kick
out of it I don't know it was a fun
mystery who done it that feels like it
exists in the same world as the first
while being completely different I'd
probably give it a solid 7.5 out of 10.
but my biggest Bugaboo was the time Jump
reveal with the twin happening Midway
like it felt like that was the big
reveal of the movie and it was a bit meh
after the fact I don't know I still had
a blast with it don't get me wrong and I
can't wait to see a third yes Netflix is
supposed to make a third one buying up
the rides so don't worry Blanc will be
back anyway I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Glass Onion did this mystery
keep you guessing until the very end and
how does this stack up with the first
Knives Out mystery and I'll let you know
we're currently running a competition
giving away three copies of Black Adam
baby and Dawn of the Dead on the 15th of
January and all you gotta do to get
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop your comments Down Below on
Glass Onion we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of last month are on screen
right now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other videos we just did
a huge breakdown for everything
everywhere all at once and
so good but with that out of the way
thanks for your constant support I've
been Jared have a great holiday I'll see
in the next one take care and peace